number one understanding the culture of
the IP I was worried this would be
another Slender Man situation where the
property is just plugged into a generic
horor movie formula but everything from
the production design to the
animatronics to the cameos which
everyone loved showed that the
filmmakers understood the assignment
number two the movie has an identity of
its own it's mostly based on the first
game but it does have elements of the
others making it harder to guess exactly
what's going to happen there's this part
where the main character is looking for
answers in his dreams that I wasn't
crazy about because it didn't feel very
FNAF but most of what they added to the
story did make it stronger and number
three it has the makings of a great
franchise it sets up the Five Nights at
Freddy's lore and now there's room for
expansion there are going to be theories
there is going to be speculation and
most importantly it's all going to lead
up to a sequel